how's it going brothers my name is
Pierre it's been a while since we did a
free horror game this one just came out
edges being really annoying go away
uh it's called dungeon nightmares I'm
not wearing any pants let's do this make
sure to use candles in dark rooms oh you
can't tell me what to do night one seven
days I can't even live half oh oh my god
no you cannot touch me she controls them
do I get a map it's not a map all right
that's pretty cool hey I wonder how this
looks like in real life okay enough of
the jokes let's see if what I eat okay
cool
so I have a condole stop again god
dammit alright so we're going out in
this how we got here
I don't know how are we gonna get out
probably won't probably gonna die a
horrible life probably gonna get jammed
skied hello
anything bad in here this Chariton
bottle some nuts
you look bad is he bad bro are you bad
what up now he's bad okay what happened
what Oh for you to blow why did I do
down I don't
what's but but hey hey boney help me so
there's a girl out there you got a do
something burning my body what are you
doing
alright I'm gonna excuse myself and dad
over here Obama don't really know what's
happening better yes pickle what's my
goal remember to use candles they said
well what if I don't have any what are
you doing okay it says which oblong what
the Hat say midnight I want to say I'm
trying I would I wasn't planning to save
anyone else if that's what you think
okay I why do I have to wear these giant
ass boots oh god that doesn't sound good
left or right or forward at all three or
four if you a discord okay for the
feminist melody fit that okay we're
going oh job blood okay we're not going
there sorry sorry Teddy what is that
what it is
this better be candles we know where you
sleep wait how do they know where I
sleep
how did they know I sleep in the women
locker room oh [ __ ] it's about this bony
high-five bunny
that's what I didn't think that cetera
at all
I said are you trying to do something or
what you hey you want you won something
huh huh you think you can moonwalk and
[ __ ] on me no you're not that cool bra
stupid stupid idiot all right let's
check our me I love those you can see
how you walk around like an idiot
alright well more exploring to do then
where you shall go left yes of course
what is that doing going this way going
this way fan-fucking-tastic
and this is spooks alright what are you
[ __ ] you all rights going here what what
what say what say what oh [ __ ] they're
coming right for me
oh [ __ ] I found oh I found the artifact
shut your [ __ ] email so where's the exit
how much supposed to find the next thing
I don't know what it find the X okay I
guess I'll try I'm gonna die I'm gonna
cry I'm gonna eat pie that's actually
okay I'm okay with even pie maybe we can
find some candles or some [ __ ] like that
I don't I don't frickin now hey gold
gold more go like a [ __ ] finally things
work out all right what are we get give
me something good more gold oh my god
Jesus Christ it's like the lottery
except I'm gonna die
nothing goddamned what I look like okay
I get it
so this is one night out of seven that's
pretty cool alright where's the exit hey
boney what's that
whoa oh you didn't move huh alright
wonder if boney will move what was I
what are you doing let me touch your
titties you're on holiday ah I am sorry
man Jesus calm down
you jab bloody feet down what is small
goddamn man don't don't don't don't do
that girl
what was that we will find you well you
already [ __ ] dead I was talking who
are you gyah she probably follows me on
Facebook she probably has told my info
this is not good
where's the exit yeah blood Tom Chaplin
okay it's fine that's that's the guy
it's really dark it's really spooks and
that's Becky hey bacon
why do you do any baking what is this no
gold please why would u s-- collect gold
it would always slow me down right no
well [ __ ] what do I know
okay I thought gold would heaven [ __ ]
okay I left and then left right
Oh JA blood don't don't
why is our problem son of a dick stain I
don't understand I don't I don't
understand what ya shh shh shh shh Isis
oh yeah I have candles okay we haven't
checked in here
pretty empty man so I just joined this
random castle to steal their gold I
deserve to die
I'm I'm a burglar well [ __ ] it I'm rich
all right in here we got this bleep what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
what'd I tell you about playing dead in
front
holy pouting was that your was that your
wife may she she's skinny hot hey all
right
hollow exit why thank you by playing the
bar gaps favorite okay it's just one
night
you woke up in seven no we're joined by
this little trite 752 come on Edgar I I
don't know what to do about it
what how dare you stop trying to be cute
no one likes you I gave you food now go
and poop somewhere I don't care
all right night - oh wait I think I
think that's my favorite night so far
yeah press space okay
so I have to do this six times seven
times I mean I'm in six more times okay
I have a candle I'm going to use it
hello anyone in here I'm lost
don't you dare Oh what did I say I told
him not to but whoa okay knock knock
who's in here it's buds eye shoosh okay
da kind of look on that one but there's
something so sexy about stop isn't that
from another game I should have known I
should have known
no no you did not just milk
I don't need milk I don't understand
oh it's you again oh now you're not
sassy the only sassy when I can lose oh
well that was easy
all right let's find the exit huh [ __ ]
ha money wrong or I guess a pony what
did you do that
huh why do you delay I heard a sound the
same and that way we're cool I'm cool
like kool-aid oh snap
I should be a rapper I don't know how to
prep crap man whatever
where's my egg let's just find the exit
I came in like a party pide I never pull
a foodie pot Oh found that [ __ ] found
that [ __ ] I'm gonna go and eat a snitch
isn't that like a vagina cuz I'm not
gonna do that night one survey survived
high-five great job we did it twice in
one video I think I woke up in one well
that's an irregular sleeping pattern I
think the dungeon grows stronger
how can a dungeon grow stronger
that explains why I died like a [ __ ]
alright fan-fucking-tastic I don't
understand why it seems like it saves
here and then if I die I go back like
that don't move it said okay that's cool
that actually helps the fact that I got
super jump scared
and didn't move helped that's great give
me an hour to forge well [ __ ] something
is behind the door
well Yolo
what you gonna do about it handles
totally not the scary Oh jab blood total
hoon never somebody jump Leyland paper
brick that Mattingly love what is that
Sam I'm standing dubstep dubstep don't
kill me dubstep won't [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she's
coming
alright I'll be going whatever way she
is not coming in you are never alone
well thank you door why I appreciate
that door you are a great person I'm
sure she it ends here well door you just
gotta look it on the bright side
sometimes don't you just don't forget
that I am leaving you y'all are torn
alone for fun okay I'm trying to run the
batter okay cam cuddles what you gonna
do about great time great time can't
wait to never go in there oh no I don't
have the artifact son of it alright tape
remember I have to make a sign so that I
can
yeah I know that ladder goddamn you smug
[ __ ] all right it made a little circle
a slew there yes I got it I got it I got
it where is the artifact Jarrett are you
an artifact yes I am quite in fact about
shut up you luck boom-boom' [ __ ] yeah
damn
alright you better be an artifact in
here I am a question a treasure hunter I
need you're not an artifact ok I'm not
moving he's touching my ass that's ok
that's great that's great chair you
touch my ass again though I'm gonna have
to cut you [ __ ] alright what a [ __ ]
perp what do we got here what a big eye
Hey huh whatever guy hello anybody want
a hole no well I don't know can we just
come friend oh yeah yeah
what's up son of a [ __ ] I don't want
more jump scared helmet that wow thanks
game thanks for listening to my little
[ __ ] request I had one thing that I
asked about one thing
even though I still love you God what
come on come on come on system we're
gonna do this together we're gonna lose
this fat together now just get that ass
chuckling jiggling way up I said it come
on
nothing great the [ __ ] did you [ __ ]
say to me you little [ __ ] that's right
[ __ ] has nice person okay many more
some fun also hello victor
i just wanna [ __ ] artifact man i
don't think that's too much to ask my
other [ __ ] is that [ __ ] art if i
yeah yes baby yes baby sexist Texas
brought me and you do the kind of stuff
that already you jingle back to put you
a dam up here I know baby I bet you fear
not what's up MA all right let's get
going
he has some Cisco years some people and
you getting two thumbs up in my but you
had enough fun Tooele things about he
you never bother me too happy
huh go go
you're almost there well rainbows I'm
sorry
810 all right hope you guys enjoyed this
episode let me know if you wanted me to
play more leave a like if you did I
really appreciate it and it helps me out
a lot and it makes me do this
whoa that's cray-cray anyway see you
tomorrow brothers love you back